good afternoon everyone
on behalf of the yale council for latin
american and iberian studies class
let me welcome
especially on behalf of her director
claudia valeja and her team she couldn't
be here
and especially to this fourth
event of the latin american policy
leader series
my name is jessica fayetta i am a senior
fellow at the jackson institute of
global affairs and lecturer on
development issues in latin america and
the caribbean
and today i have the distinct pleasure
and honor to welcome our speaker mariano
elvaeza the regional director for latin
america and caribbean in a very
important institution of the united
nations you and women
it is a particular pleasure because
mariano elle and i are colleagues
from the united nations for the longest
time i have been in the past before
coming to yale 30 years in the united
nations and a big part of this
we have been colleagues
with with and friends good friends with
with maria noel
and um
both we have worked in latin america and
the caribbean we have coincided in in
many ways uh most recently when i was
assistant secretary general and regional
director um
in in the region
so i can attest firsthand that of her
knowledge about the region
her
expertise but most importantly her
commitment
to in this case to the advancement of
women so she is a
really a
fantastic guest for this policy series
the title of her talk is
diversity equality and gender
and i think you will agree with me that
this subject is particularly relevant
to reflect on this not only in latin
america and caribbean but i think even
in the country that we are right now
holding this and of course in yale
university where this subject is also of
great interest to to to the students and
faculty we hope that uh today's event
will provide a a forum for for
discussing the the role of organizations
such as you and women
uh to for the advancement of uh
diversity and and and gender
the latin america and policy
leaders series um organized by clients
seeks to create dialogue about the the
future of democratization human rights
and development with policy leaders from
across latin america in the caribbean
with this initiative kleis hopes to
engage leaders from the region in
vigorous and respectful discussions
about pressing issues
while also benefiting from their years
of experience so certainly it is an
honor for me to be invited to to to host
and to moderate the talk of maria noel
as she possesses the the right kind of
experience that we need to hear right
now
so let me tell you a little bit about
about marianoel
she assumed her functions as regional
director for the americas in the
caribbean in u.n women in 2019 but
before that she worked as the director
of the program division at the at
headquarters um and she's she joined
from another un organization unops
um where she served as the director for
global portfolio and before that
partnerships practice
in a strategic partnership so she has a
long and distinguished career in the
united nations she also spent
eight years in undp where she held
various posts including a senior advisor
deputy resident representative in
paraguay and senior manager for the
recovery reconciliation
and reform program
she also has a distinguished career in
in public service in her own country
because prior to joining the united
nations
maria noel held multiple positions in
eurowise ministry of foreign affairs
including as political counsellor
at the ui embassy to the united states
and as delegate of uruguay to the united
nations general assembly
she also was an alternate representative
of worldwide to the world bank board of
directors mariano l is a national firm
from uruguay she holds a doctorate of
law and social sciences from university
of the republic of uruguay and she also
has a master's degree in international
in public policy from john hopkins
university in washington dc
the
structure of today
is something you have already are
familiar with she will have her talk
we will then follow with some
moderate discussion which you are
invited to raise your hand and i am
particularly welcoming all the people
all the students and faculty who are in
public in general who are joining us
right now on online
um before turning the the microphone to
our speaker i would like to thank the
sponsors of this event
the latin american policy leader serious
is generously supported by the george
herbert walker jr lecture fund in
international studies at the macmillan
center for international studies and
this event would not have been possible
without the assistance of the
collaborators such as the office of
international affairs
the fox international fellowship program
and the program from peace and
development and if i may also add the
jackson institute for global affairs
to which i belong
thank you to the staff and the
colleagues who made this visit possible
and without further ado maria noel you
have the floor
i feel so old every time i hear my cv
it means that i've been around for some
time thank you jessica it's a real
pleasure and honor to be here and also
being introduced by such a distinguished
colleague as jessica
we known each other for a long time as
well but jessica has been a leader in
our region and
and also we are very happy to see that
that she's here in yale i i think that
we practitioners we have something to
say and to transmit but it not
not always happens that that we have
this opportunity so i'm really grateful
for yale and for the faculty for all the
the colleagues that has been uh so kind
with me since i arrived yesterday so
thank you so much uh for giving me this
opportunity um
for me it's it's very important to bring
to your attention
what is your women what are we doing
and why is important to focus on women's
issues
and women in all the diversity because
we are not
uh you know the same women that's why
the concept of intersectionality is so
dear to to young women so i would like
to to start by saying what do we do um
in um
well i don't know it doesn't work
but i would like to to share with you
what is the situation of equality of
gender equality and or gender inequality
as well but what are the key areas of
young women where do we work in the
region and how do we see
gender inequality in our region and what
are the solutions that we are proposing
because we try to focus in certain
solutions
before
you know instead of being everywhere we
try to to focus and try to to move the
needle as we say and try to change the
reality of women so we we
we do um three things basically in our
mandate from the general assembly we
were created 11 years ago we are really
young for the un
and we were created as a merge of
several institutions that were dealing
bits and pieces of gender and it was a
very intelligent decision i must say
from the general assembly because we
could really merge the specialization
that we're in the un uh everywhere and
we we had the opportunity to have our
first executive director was mother
michel bachelet the former president of
chile and right now she is the high
commissioner of human rights so it was a
real honor to have her with us i was not
a new woman at that time but i was
envious of the young women colleagues
because they had such a distinguished
executive director and we
we decided at that time that we should
focus our attention on women political
participation women in the public space
on women economic empowerment the
autonomy of women because we
really are half of the population of the
world
but we are not contributing to the
economy as half a population of the
world and that's why the world is not
growing enough because we are not enough
participating and of course violence
against women which is the biggest
i would say shadow pandemic that we have
that came more in light during the
pandemic because it was obvious that
this was a big issue that everybody
needed to attend and of course we are
universal we are global so women peace
and security is a very important part of
our work and the humanitarian response
of what we do in that parts of the world
but
you know i didn't know when i came to
latin america when i came back to latin
america
that
the region was going to be in such
enormous problems i thought it was a
nice position to be to really
establish innovation to try to work
differently from other un agencies and
you know calmly integrate our work a
gender perspective in the work of the
other un agencies
and suddenly we have social unrest
everywhere it was chile it was bolivia
it was ecuador it was colombia it was
everywhere and it was a really a boost
of energy
coming from the women's movement because
it started on the 8th of march in
santiago de chile and then in continue
to uprising the indigenous population in
ecuador but it was women's movement
indigenous women movement that were
behind
and of course then we have it in
colombia and bolivia was in chaos
because of the coup d'etat so so it was
everywhere and i said what is going on
in my region i thought we were
overcoming the governance issues
but but it wasn't and it isn't and it's
a big question mark what is going to
happen with our governance
what is going to happen with gender
equality we have only one president who
declared himself feminist which is boric
the president of chile but rapidly he's
losing popularity
so he doesn't even have 100 days and
he's already been a pariah in many
aspects in in his uh country and we have
the constitutional reform in chile that
is also a beacon of hope how the women's
issues are going to be uh
you know in the constitution so
here we are trying to
attend all this
and suddenly the pandemic came
but we knew that 74 percent of who was
in the front lines of the pandemic were
women
but only 20 percent of women were at the
forefront of the decision-making so
there you start seeing the gap
the discrimination
and the lack of
understanding that women have also assay
and they have a say that perhaps is
innovative is different
you can only look at how
the leaders 11
of the leaders of the world are women
and if you see those countries those
countries manage
the pandemic very well
like the prime minister of new zealand
the chancellor of germany the prime
minister of norway of finland so there
is a common threat that women perhaps
has a different way of leadership
of making sure that everybody is in the
table before taking decision
listening more
and of course we don't know everything
so we need to consult so perhaps this
kind of leadership
with these soft skills that we call them
you know is what the world needs right
now to really confront
several crises at the same time like the
pandemic brought the in into light so
for us
in latin america
it has been
a horrible consequence the pandemic for
women
we were a region that was growing the
participation of women in the economy
and the pandemic stopped that
very much so
and now we went back 18 years
we went back 18 years because of one
reason which is care
we women
are the main care providers
and suddenly the world realized that
care is very important because
most of the covet
patients were at home being care by whom
by women
so
care came
to the front line
and care came as
saying this is an unpaid care work that
we do
more than everybody else
so we have weeks of eight days
because our work is is to care and our
work
without recognition
without redistribution
and without reduction of the unpaid care
work and unfortunately although we
thought this was going to be changing
the pandemic it didn't women continue to
do three times more
care and pay care work than men
and in some countries we did a surveys
like in chile
it increased the unpacked work of men
seven minutes
seven minutes when we had the children
at home would we have to
be there for them for the education when
we had to take care of elderly take care
of this of the children it means that
men are not being core responsible of
the household of the education of
children of taking care of their own
elderly because normally women take care
of their own energy and the elderly of
their partner so
unfortunately this requires the
attention not just from from us as young
women the u.n system but also from civil
society from governments and
particularly from the social media i
think the power of the social media
right now
give us the opportunity to really change
this behavior
and understand that without
the core responsibility of men in the
household it's impossible for women to
really thrive and participate and that's
why women are not searching actively for
jobs in my region because they have to
stay home and and provide care this is
why my number one priority with all my
colleagues in the region we are 550
gender experts in the region in 26
countries so we are quite a quite a
crowd there and we decided to focus our
attention on systems of care
the society of care we will have the
regional conference of women in
argentina on the first week of november
second week of november we have this
regional conference for the last 45
years is in the family of eclaq is
intergovernmental conference the first
one was in lavana 45 years ago so it
means that this is
an institution that we need to preserve
and the subject is society of care not
just the care of people but the care of
biodiversity the care of of climate so
for us
establishing integrated system of care
that integrate not just
the federal levels the
subnational levels and municipal level
but private and public and also
community level because indigenous
population they do care in a different
manner that we need to integrate so
that's what we're working we're working
in 12 countries to
establish the legal framework to
establish the costing how much it cost
to the to the government to to finance a
care system that it is an investment
because we always say that it has three
dividends the first dividend is
the care to to the family the welfare of
the family because when you have an
elderly a sick person a disabled kids
very small kids when you have
professional
support everybody will be happier and
particularly the woman that is doing
their care and pay care
the second is for the economy because
there is a creation of jobs that is very
important and is a green economy it's a
they call it the the orange economy
because this is not polluting but you
are given the opportunity to those women
that are working in the informal sector
normally as a
domestic worker
you have to give them the opportunity to
study to do a certification
and to really go out there and be
caregivers more professional so we
reckon that this will create millions of
jobs and it will dignify
the women that are working in the
informal sector that don't have benefits
that don't have anything except the
little salary they receive when
they receive it because in the in the
pandemic we saw that they some of them
were slaves they were not allowed to
leave the houses because of their
contagious and we believe that those
jobs will be paying for taxes so the
system that we are
trying to to create everywhere will pay
by itself
there is an initial investment but then
it will be paid by itself by the
creation of jobs in the care economy and
the third dividend is for women to have
the opportunity to go
out and work and and of course get out
of poverty because the moment the women
have
subsidies to for care or the women can
provide
proper care for their own she goes to
work and of course she will invest back
in in their own family so for us that's
a priority together with financial
inclusion so we will we are trying as
well to
make sure that the different
investors banks
you know
crowd fans
venture capitalists you name it fintechs
everybody
have a special consideration of women
because unfortunately we are only 11
of targets
so this is not possible that 89
of the funds are channeled to men
we need to change that reality and for
that we open up a platform and what
we're trying to do is to bring everybody
and we call it the platform for engender
investments and
there are three things that for me are
essential there one is
those are investments that are going to
yield very positive desire the results
you're going to make money by investing
in women and also you are giving the
opportunity to those
companies or entrepreneurs that are
trying to get out of of their micro
enterprise learning
lending that
it's all well and good but you never get
out of poverty to scale up their
entrepreneurs entrepreneur
objectives
and really you know provide this
opportunity to women to thrive and and
and the third for me which is essential
is
the
impact of the social investment because
you are not only investing in women you
are investing in the community where
women is in certain and for that we have
seven principles that we call it the the
women economic empowerment principles
that
help the private sector and the private
banks and the private capitals to
understand that this is not just one
investment this is i know an overarching
um framework uh to to be successful for
for an investment
and then of course women political
participation is still for us very
important we have only 32 percent of
women in parliament but we have
very important examples of parity in all
like it was in the last elections in
mexico there was a political decision to
say
let's have elections parity in
everywhere
governors municipal level the the
parliament and this is working very
nicely it's a it's a it's a lab
of parity in the world and then bolivia
that declared parity many years ago and
we still have uh 51 percent of women in
the senate so this is also very nice and
also costa rica argentina they are
countries that they have work uh through
different laws uh you know how to get to
parity or to quarters but the rest of
the region we're still quite low in
women political participation not just
in the parliament but also
as
as mayors we have only 15 percent of
women mayors in latin america 15 is
nothing
of course we have
mexico city we have bogota which are
enormous cities but uh anyway you know
we need to push women more
at the local level and
for us also it is important to actions
uh at the public sector which is the
gender
responsive budget the national budgets
are still the most important development
instrument that a country has
but it doesn't have a gender length so
we really need to work different
methodologies uh to to push for gender
budgets and gender planning and gender
statistics etc what you don't count it
doesn't exist and most of the time
women are completely invisible and women
of color or women of indigenous
as descendant on lg tv why
bi they are completely invisible so we
need to work on on those statistics to
bring them to the light
then women economic empowerment as i was
saying the economy of care and financial
inclusion are the things that we have
prioritized because we believe they need
the most and of course violence against
women violence against women is is a
horrible problem that we have if you can
think uh in mexico there are 12 women
that dying a day
just for the sake of being a woman
so we really need to to and and we have
more or less 4 000 feminine sides a year
um in the region so so those are daring
uh data that we need to change the
reality and how do we change that
by changing legal frameworks by making
sure that we have the data because it's
very you know it's very scattered the
data so we really need to and to have um
you know centers of care centers uh that
can care women when they are uh first uh
being victims of islands right um so so
this is what we normally do
we work with a framework we wait with
data we work with integrated
integrated different
inter-agencies response that government
has etcetera
and and then of course for us it's
essential to
understand
the financial of those gender programs
and we are pushing for stents women in
stems we don't have enough girls so
adolescent studies the careers of the
future
or the career of the present
so we need women in technology that's
why we have several initiatives to
introduce women to technology to science
etc we're still only 30 of women that
are studying or working in in the stems
area in in the region
so and and the last uh point for me will
be
um democracy governance social unrest
and all the things that we have been
watching all around in in the media but
also
the lack of opportunity for women to be
in the decision-making tables and to
bring their own
perspective which is different from men
but also the solutions because women
have very important solutions as mothers
as
you know community leaders
they can see things in a different
perspective and they can help uh
governments and and civil society and
private sector to to bring a different
perspective and and a different uh human
development if i may say so i would like
to stop there and
thank you very much for listening and
and i'm here for answering any questions
and receiving recommendations as well
but thank you so much
thank you mariano can i invite you to
okay to sit here so we can now have a
conversation
this is comfortable
thank you very much you have
given us really a
uh a
very sobering i think a situation on
what what is happening in latin america
and the caribbean with regard
to diversity to the situation of women
but i also found it very
encouraging
that you are
working and focusing on very specific uh
solutions especially when you talk about
the
systems integral systems of care and
also
uh empowering of women with very clear
solutions going forward
let me open for for some uh questions
before i have some questions of my own
but i i'd like to give the opportunity
to to the students and also to
the public who is connected to
to give us some questions so
anybody that has some questions please
raise your hands
well well they get uh well this oh here
we have uh
please please introduce yourself from
what school you are what year and uh
go ahead with your question
my name is daryl i'm a first year
master's student at the jackson
institute
um i was wondering i didn't i was
wondering if were there any thoughts
about
paying
just women
just for being at home in general so
you mentioned having care workers come
in and allow women to go out and work
but
paying women for the work that they
already do without like any policy
discussions around that or
yes thank you for your question and yes
indeed uh in my country uruguay it
exists a a sort of a payment
for staying home mothers
and it's a
it's it's a subsidy i wouldn't like to
call it subsidy because if you
analyze the time that women spend in
care
it could get to 20 of the gdp we did
that study in mexico in colombia
and it's much more than oil and minerals
that that everything so it means that
the development of the country is in the
shoulders of women so this is a payment
that uh the government of uruguay
colombia panama
argentina they decided to do to women to
stay home and care
and it's it's working very nicely
because
some of the of the women are saying i'd
rather stay home that that be out there
and what we notice is that
we
we did a study some years ago about
the
pyramid of women
the the women that are in the basis of
the pyramid
women that
were mothers because they were
raped at 15 or 16 years
they are very poor they don't they
haven't finished their education
those women if they want to go out for
work
they have to adapt themselves
to get a care
provider so we have internal debt of the
most poor of the women
because there isn't a system of care
that can allow them to
to to go to work and and to get out of
poverty or go back to study or etc so
for us uh this has been something that
we really brought into the attention
there are some women that want to stay
home
they need to have that payment but there
are some women that they want more from
life they want to continue studying so
we we really when we provide the
i would say the technical assistance we
put all this so we were discussing with
the minister of social affairs of chile
on this respect to map how many women
are how much this is gonna cost so we
create a different methodology of
costing of the different care you know
care provider the person that wants to
stay home how much uh the payment but we
should pay attention to
the time that women use us on a daily
basis for care
and that has a value
and it
is more valuable that any industry in
the country
but uh but yes this is part of our or
our toolkit of advice to to governments
please
hi my name is brianna i'm graduating
student at the jackson institute for
global affairs i'm also mexican and i
worked last summer with e-clack helping
them plan their regional conference for
women
my question for you is how to foster
political will in the political climate
that is going on right now in latin
america to incentivize these governments
that right now have so many needs to
cover to make that initial investment in
women how to convince presidents how to
convince the ministries of finance to
listen to the ministries of the women
and
invested money in care systems
thank you for your for your question
mucha gracias
well
we are trying to convince them and last
sunday the president of argentina and
argentina is in a big big trouble
economically he announced
that he was sending the law for creating
the care system and he put it as an
investment
we did the talking points
i can
i hope it doesn't get out of care
but
it was a convincing not just from the
ministry of gender but also from
different arguments economic arguments
the the the meeting we have with the
minister of economy was pure economic
value of uh of the investing in in the
in the care city and i i remember his
his face he looked at us and said okay i
will i accept that
so when you bring numbers when you
compare industries
we did a study in turkey
together with undp and the university of
ankara to compare the infrastructure
sector and the care system that we
wanted the ministry of finance to invest
and he was convinced with the sheer
numbers
and and i guess that
we people who work in development and
and
with gender issues
normally we are seen as you know the
crazy feminists that go and march and
and we're not that we are that a
plus and and i guess that
but continue the studies and deepening
the study that's why i'm so happy to be
here because it's so important that
academia takes the focus
out of the the agenda uh that is a
traditional agenda of gender which we
need to continue because human rights is
super important for us and we have to
put it at the center but we also have to
analyze you know
these things that i'm saying about
getting the autonomy of women
economic empowerment because i am
convinced that the more autonomy a woman
is
the less likely she will be
uh a victim of violence so
i think that things are related and also
she will have the leadership skills as
well to become a politician so
i mean i i tend to be romantic and
believe in all that
it's good to be
romantic especially because
we need people who are convinced of this
and i think i cannot think of
better colleagues and you and women to
pass this this passion um i i want to to
ask you a question of my own while you
know students think of of all the
questions you mentioned about
the importance of
investing
in in women's projects
uh we have some some uh students from
from business school right and of course
at the end of the day
not nobody is going to invest just
because they are women's project they
need to be as you said
good business
so tell us a little bit more about this
fund that you that uh that that you're
proposing as uh as
especially to the venture capitalists
yeah
so i'm not proposing a fund i'm
proposing a platform of knowledge
because i remember the first time we
invited
jp morgan and
citibank and there was a lot of american
banks but also european bank and we did
it with the university
of the empresa
spain with
susana malcorra that used to be
the chief of staff
of bankimo the former secretary general
and she was also minister for an affairs
of argentina susana called me and said
how can we work together in this so we
decided to create this platform together
with the european union the european
bank of reconstruction but
we were talking about
investments that yield
very positive results
but are products for women
women's led organizations or
entrepreneurs
and also services for women and i'll
give you an example and there
i found by researching uh
who is who in the financial world and
why is it that they are not investing in
women and i came across with the first
unicorn of the region
and and she she was called herself the
pink unicorn she's little like this
she's from argentina and she lives in
miami so i want to see her and said how
did you manage to get
one billion dollar for women's
investment and she said it was
very difficult i had to navigate
a lot of
sexual harassment i had to navigate a
lot of
sexuals conversation
bias bias
from men
that they just wanted to have dinner or
lunch with me just for the sake of it
and
it took only one man that was a big
investor that realized
i hear you i will invest in you and when
he decided
then he came across many others and one
of the investments that was the first
investment that that she came across
was an american
biotechnology that she invented and and
most women are going to sympathize with
me a machine to do the mammography
but with a gender lens is it's a machine
that captures your your your
your breast
and you don't have to be squeezed as it
is which is horrible the way it is now
because of course it was done by a man
because no women can really invent a
machine like that so she decided
she decided to create this this this
machine
and also is mobile so it means that you
can go to rural areas etc so
you know she came with this investment
of 20 million dollars and this man
realized
that
this is a money-making machine so he
invested 100 million dollars so the
american lady said oh my gosh what i'm
gonna do now with this this kind of
money so now he she is producing uh the
the machines and most likely you you
will benefit from from that but this is
an example of a product and a service
that is done with the gender lens
and and it took one month to realize
that we really need to to achieve that
so that's what we're trying to do to
educate the financial sector to
understand that they are biases and and
we need um a test with the idb the
inter-american development bank research
department we send 20 actors and
actresses 10 men and 10 women in
santiago chile to get a loan from a bank
the same conditions everything they were
young they were 28
and
20 percent of women were rejected the
loans
just because they were women
and then we realized
that the risk analysts were 99 men
and the bias was oh you are
at the age of conception most likely you
will be a mother so you will not pay me
the loan why i mean
99
of the return of debt women are fa at 99
responsible much more than men that are
80 percent
so this bias we needed to explain we
needed to educate and of course when we
went to to we had a meeting with the
presidents of the banks they were all
men
you know
and when i presented i said you lost
six billion dollars of business because
of the bias
what they said
there you go when you have bias
when you don't understand the product
and service that women wants to do
and and the fact that women are most
likely
more inclined to work as a network
the sorority of women the association
comparatives
you know you name it we could be a force
of nature the energy that women of the
region has we can be out of poverty
very soon
so so this is what we are fighting you
know the the the protagonism uh this
bias this these ways of
not understanding the diversity how the
diversity can help uh for the business
environment
so so this is what we are trying to do
with this platform great story mariano
el the great story
uh any more questions from from the
audience
please
we have
my name is mariana i'm from school of
the environment i'm graduating this year
as well
and i was wondering if within you and
women there have been talks about how to
create cultural change
maybe at the local level in schools
because i i think one of the biggest
barriers for women's empowerment and
women equality in the region is even
when women have the opportunity they
weren't raised to feel like they were
capable of taking those roles and the
men around them are not encouraging them
to take those roles so how how do we
address that in in a way that's
respectful to of course to the region
and to the current norms but building
towards a more equal society for all
thank you for the question we are doing
it by
three things we work a lot with unesco
and with unicef as well other un
agencies that are more in education than
us um we did a pro we have a program
that is called um
second chance education
uh in mexico and in chile those are
pilot projects financed by a private
foundation and what we're doing there is
to reach out to those women that
left the education system because of
what you're saying because they were
early mothers
early pregnancies and because they were
pushed by their partners
to stay home
because they didn't have a
self-confidence uh
so this program is about self-confidence
it's about rebuilding
uh the willpower of women
and most likely those women are victims
of psychological violence right so so we
have 2 000 women in mexico
not in mexico city in two states
and what i saw was incredible because i
met them the first day that we started
the the program nobody
dared to talk
they were crying all the time you know
they were
you know they're nervous and and with
fear
what is going to happen if my husband
sees that i'm here and then two years
later
i came to to visit the program i
couldn't believe what i saw you know
those women with self-confidence i am an
entrepreneur i handle the money now if
he doesn't like it he can live
you know
and they say oh my god what happened
here so by building their self-esteem um
and it's not traditional education if
you want but it's the education they
need
and in the pandemic most of them lost
their entrepreneurial
initiatives but they rebuilt others
and
the most important thing that i saw was
a network between indigenous women
between
women that were
discriminated because of their age
because they were too young or too old
you know so
we have to tackle the self
uh confidence because that's why
uh it's been too many centuries
of
telling you can't do it because you're a
woman you can't do it because you're a
woman so there is building your genes
you can't do it because you're a woman
you know so so we have to remake it and
we have to understand that
self-confidence will take you very far
away and will allow you to to to be
brilliant in whatever you do
and and i think we are still in the era
of first time first time an astronaut
women that goes to the moon first time a
woman becomes a unicorn first time a
woman is president so we are still in
that area you know so
what we need is accelerators
we need the accelerated by changing the
behavior and
to answer your question we are using
behavioral science
we are using positive deviance
um we are trying to bring
uh
all the menu of
of things that are happening in
innovation not just
but i think behavioral science new
neuroscience
it's important to to use it to change
community and also
and that that's my last point we are
working with religious leaders
uh because religion is part of our life
uh
and and
you know i realized by working with
religious leaders of all
different religious
they didn't even know they were doing
the discrimination or they didn't even
realize
how much harm they were doing to women
so
it was so so interesting to work with
catholic priests uh pastors from
different denominations muslins we have
an enormous network that that we work on
a regular basis and
you know they thought that feminist was
about abortion was about you know
shouting in the streets so they didn't
realize all these things
and they say you're right we need to
respect the dignity of women that is
every religion the dignity of women so
so so that's what we're and that's why
for us human rights
of women are essential and and central
to to our work
i would say mariano this is so important
what you just said and of course we're
counting on
yale students yes male and female who
are going to become
world leaders we're going to get the
jobs to also think about this in in
advance because
it also this self-esteem for for women
it also
is part of being
looking at role models like like
many of you will be
um and and pull other women and and you
know you're going to be working in your
countries many of you are from from from
our region so i we are counting on them
yes so i think we have uh
one more question from
juan the gentleman juan
thank you so much
first year master student at the jackson
institute for global affairs from
colombia
and one of the many questions some of
which we have like started to answer but
i guess my main one is
how does the challenges of working to
empower women between rural and urban
areas changes because it's still kind of
an urban movement than the rural ones
are even like in a worse condition so uh
what are the difference in the
challenges and how are you
like creating different strategies to
make sure that also like rural women are
empowered properly
thank you for your question and yes it's
it's
different the objectives in life
but it's also different the context and
the context for equality and diversity
is very important as well um i would say
that
in colombia in particular after the
peace agreements we have a hundred
provisions of gender equality in the
peace agreement so we are working with
women that were most affected by by the
conflict um so so for us it has been an
amazing opportunity to realize the
leadership
that is emerging in rural areas
indigenous women afro-descendant women
and their voice will never be
shut down i can tell you once they
started they are amazing leaders and we
have the opportunity perhaps
we don't know yet but there is a
very prominent afro-descendant leader
that is candidate to be vice president
and this is the first time that is
happening in the country so i hope that
um
you know the rural women
have the same needs other urban women
but
they've been treated differently
in the self-esteem they need the same
things in the political participation as
well
and the economic empowerment as well and
they suffer violence the same
i think it's the intensity
and it's the lack of networks
and so that's why we need to push for
for more networks and we need to be more
aware from the un in particular to these
amazing women that are emerging as
leaders and bring them to the table
normally we tend to work with urban
leaders because they are the most noisy
but we need to be
caring
for the one that are left behind and i
see in the region it's emerging
a lot of indigenous women
afro-descendant women we had an amazing
leader in the vice president of costa
rica uh she's afraid ascendant and costa
rica you never think that there is an
afro uh descending population that is a
minority but is extremely important
and i think that the more
we have the more we have to integrate
them and and you know provide them with
opportunities of
more training or more exposure uh we we
we went to the security council uh with
the
ma the mothers of
cepul sarco it was a location in
guatemala where the women were
systematically raped as a instrument of
war
so we demonstrated this is the only case
in the world
that
by weaponizing
the sexual
slavery um
the national law condemned the
militaries it's the first
so we went to to the security and it was
only indigenous women who were telling
their story in their own language
because they didn't speak spanish
so
you know we're trying to to make role
models uh to bring them
uh
to to to the tables and and to the
conversations you know that with the
pandemic we were all the time in swoon
you know but but they didn't have
technology so they didn't have access 40
of the women in latin america they don't
have computers they don't have access to
internet 40 and we are talking about you
know 40 or 300 million
um so
you know by
by trying to listening to them because
they are
solution makers for climate changes
adaptation climate changes mitigation to
preserve the biodiversity so it is so so
important to to listen to them and
integrate their demands in the and also
the feminist movement is very particular
because they don't like young
they don't like the young
because they say they don't know they
don't have experience hello
what are you talking about so we had a
lot of problems with the traditional
feminists
they didn't want it
the younger generation they don't have
an ngo they are movements they will
disappear no
so i have an advisory board as a
regional director and
they are so diverse this is the first
time they are very diverse because i
brought young
from every every
intersectionality and the traditional
feminists say how come i'm not in your
board
you will never be
because you don't bring the diversity
and i need to listen to what are they
and also i brought one man so everybody
was indignated how can you bring them
and because we they are the solution
to our problems as well so
i think that we need to listen to each
other much more we need to work much
more with men
and and we need to bring leaders that
are respectful of the dignity of women
no matter where we come from the
intersectionality is critical and and
human rights are still
you know the values
that that we need to to defend
uh otherwise i i i am not very
optimistic of what is happening in the
region from from political side
but i am very optimistic with the youth
of the region and and of course the
women of the region
thank you very much maria noel for
this wonderful talk of so many important
issues that you have brought
and especially for for showing here at
yale uh how broad and how new the the
gender diversity agenda is and so many
topics that uh that
are still on the table that need to
evolve
um i would like we have
literally two minutes before we we cut
so i i would like to to to ask you a
final
question is um your your recommendation
that you would like to leave
the yale students yes um
so many as you can tell they are
interested and i have seen them in my
classes how engaged how interested they
are
how can they contribute to advance uh
gender and diversity uh not only in our
region in latin america and the
caribbean but in in in their own in
their own um it's where they're going to
be moving and working going forward well
first of all
you are the leaders of the future as
jessica was saying and and i think that
you will be
much
broader leaders if you understand
the gender dimension in all the aspects
that we were discussing
i believe that
yale as a fantastic institution it is
if you do more research on these matters
if you put your
you know your focus
on researching these alternative issues
of gender because normally academic
focus
on human rights on
public policies that needs to be done
but i would say that sometimes the
research
does not match
what is happening in the region
so it would be great if we can have you
students to come more to the region and
to
bring the amazing academic structures
that that you are receiving here
to to latin america because we still
have
very poor
universities poor in the sense
that
we are not modernized i i see when i
talk with with students that they think
in a new unilateral way
they are not
crossing different frontiers and i think
that we need to do much more
cross-fertilization
work
yesterday i have the privilege to have
dinner with fellow students from turkey
from israel from mongolia from germany
and they are doing amazing work i was so
excited to listen to them thank you very
much for you to or she's doing our
research on on an amazing issue why is
it that women
in turkey are voting conservative when
when the conservative government is
pushing women to be much more
conservative so there is there are so
many issues that you guys can have the
the luxury to research being in a such a
prestigious institution so i really
would like to see much more research
being done
on these issues cross-fertilized
on different regions of the world
because we are called the middle income
region but we are the most unequal
region in the world and we are still
with low productivity with so much
inequality
how can we get out of this trap that we
are as a region so economic factor
financial factors climate changes so all
all these factors it's not just gender
issues it's like how the perspective of
of women can and can be studied there
and and for me also it would be an honor
if we can have some of yous
coming to you and women we have offices
in many countries
our regional offices in panama but we
have offices in our biggest offices in
colombia and then we have in haiti in
the caribbean in mexico argentina you
name it brazil so so you're much welcome
to come
to our offices to do your research in in
situ and and that would be great
so thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity and i hope that i put some
seed of
of trying to continue working in gender
issues but in different dimensions thank
you thank you so much for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you